alain delon star du jour sur antenne 2
delon nous expliquera pourquoi ils
craquent en ce moment pour la télévision
bonsoir et merci
un bombardier libyen abattu à djamena
par un missile français
le raid aérien est une riposte à la
déception pareil tchadien d'une base
militaire en territoire libyen
entre les deux allemagnes cette poignée
de main historique à bonn le numéro un
est allemands passent cinq jours à
l'ouest avec la bénédiction de mode foot
le grand retour des péronistes en
argentine la défaite aux législatives
des radicaux du président alphonsine
reste d'ouvrir une nouvelle période
d'instabilité politique l'époque n'ont
pas le moral salaire médiocre manque de
considération beaucoup d'entre eux
rentrent cette année avec un brin de
vague à l'âme les frasques de big mac à
flushing meadow plus grossier que jamais
le champion américain écope d'une amende
record et frôlé l'élimination
une journée supplémentaire de détention
pour marcel carton
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann jean
louis normandin d'antenne 2 et roger
auque les otages français au liban n'ont
toujours pas été libérés aux à des
titres